you know mtnt sideline reporter also for
Bleacher Report okay Chris you reported
that Damon Giannis have discussed for
years joining forces even though for us
in the basketball Community this feels
like it came out of nowhere I know
you've been on boots on the ground
through this entire situation can you
break down how long this has been
building and what caused it to happen
now
yeah it really didn't take it really
didn't take long as far as how this
trade came came about obviously we've
known throughout the whole All Season
that Jamie Lewis
you know he requested the trade and he
wanted to see in Miami the Miami Heat
was a team of the preference he felt
like they were one piece away
from just being that true title
contended team and he thought he can get
you know them get to that get to that
elusive championship
uh but the Portland Trail Blazers just
refused to even Engage The Miami Heat
the only conversation Miami and Portland
had was a phone conversation during
summer league in Las Vegas and at that
point the Miami Heat they were just
trying to just get a sit down in
Portland refuse and so it was this this
went on All Summer Long all summer long
ago
Portland try but just find any students
that would feel a competitive offer but
what they found out those offers were
limited because
you know Damian Lewis agent Aaron
Goodwin you know he kind of put the word
out that game would not be happy being
in any other situation other than Miami
and so that kind of limited the offer
the attractive officers I should say but
it just got to a point where
training camp it was a few weeks away
and what I've told I'm about to throw in
depth
um in this in the story that I'm writing
for police report on how this really all
came about but I can tell you that uh
you know the Milwaukee Bucks were
brought in
let me see probably uh battle a little
bit over a week ago and it happened
really fast and that that's that's all I
can say right now but if the bus jumped
in really fast a little bit over a week
ago and they got in the mid and they
really and they found out like they
really had a serious opportunity and
then the um for the for the book or for
the buck standpoint you know it was the
hard part the difficult task of
include Drew holiday in a deal and that
that that was a tough situation right
there but they felt like gave me a
little body of what the Milwaukee Bucks
organization is all about family
competitive trying to do things the
right way and then they they out you
know beyond Us in and Dane real good
friends and just for just to put this
out there
Giannis is um
you know his his fiancee Mariah that's
my cousin and you know I'm from Fresno
she's from Fresno so uh during the off
season He he'll go down to Fresno and
kick it was kicking with our family but
he went and I tweeted about this he went
to a barber shop at the famous
Barbershop
um in our in our city of Fresno called
phase two and he was just answering all
types of questions from people that was
at the barbershop and he was just
unfiltered and they asked him you know
what's the one player you want to play
with that you've never ever played with
you had to pick one and that player was
Damian Lillard and we see with Giannis
I'm sorry to be long-winded but I'm
trying to keep as much as possible you
see with the the comments that Giannis
made over the last couple of weeks about
hey you know the team still has to do
right you know I'm not sold and locked
in to any situation long term they still
need to do things and put pieces
together to put us in a great chance to
compete for championships year after
year well definitely getting the star
player of Damon's caliber and getting
the player that Gianna said he wants to
play with I definitely think uh I
definitely think that answers the call
right there so a lot of things happen
behind the scenes I'm gonna get into it
I please encourage people to vote
um bleach a report when I when I get
this story out but uh it's a lot
transpired overall season to get to this
point Well you certainly had a lot of
layers there right so I want to go back
about four steps because that story you
told about Giannis in the barbershop in
Fresno is incredible and the fact that
the Bucks were only in on this for a
week but like you said Miami was linked
for so long and they offered so much so
for the Portland Trailblazers to make
this deal and what they got in return
um did they not feel like the Miami
offer was enough or did they feel as if
we're not going to give in to Damian
Lillard's demand of wanting to go to
Miami because I feel like there needs to
be a distinction there that it just
seems like it's a bit murky right now
yeah Chris that's a good question man I
mean if you look at what Portland got in
return you know they got you all day who
they're looking to ship out and get more
Assets in return but they got a 2029
first round pick and they got two um oh
stop rice so some people will say well
if they engage Miami
they they probably would have had a
better deal a better overall package and
so you know I picked myself for
everybody else to kind of break down and
see what they think as far as who who
would have who would have been able to
present a better offer um but I could
tell you right now Portland felt fully
they didn't they you know they felt like
with Damien only
requesting a trade to one team that it
limited
um they limited their pool and even you
know even with this deal that they I
guess they felt was satisfactory they
made a deal from Milwaukee you know this
is this is not usually the type of haul
that you get for a player of his caliber
and so uh you know I I think I think it
speaks to just really how messy this
whole summer was
um between the the two sides or two
sides I'm talking about
um
Daniel Lillard his agent um Aaron
Goodwin in the Portland Trailblazer you
know so a lot Chris a lot went on behind
the scenes man but I think at the end of
the day I spoke with Dame
um brief
uh when we got word of the trade
and he was wrapping his mind around it
you know he's wrapping his mind around
it
um the idea of going to Milwaukee you
know he has you know he had his mind set
on where he wanted to go but you know he
he's just trying to clear things out for
you know get his family situated and
everything he's trying to think through
those things but he understands that
this is a great opportunity great
opportunity on the basketball court to
do something special to to if this is
this is his best chance of actually
really getting to contend and compete
for a championship so he's excited about
that but you know he's still in the
process of just just trying to let it
all sink in
one more question for you it involves
the Phoenix Suns who have been
incredibly active since uh Matt ishpia
purchased the team right and I go okay I
thought this team had made as many moves
as they can make when did they get in
involved in this as a third team as part
of this process
yeah well Phoenix thought a deal could
be done by the weekend and so what is
this is Wednesday and so you know they
were prepared
um Portland reached out to them last
week
um on the possibility of
acquiring DeAndre ayton somebody who
Portland has you know had his eyes on
for a while and you look at the you look
at the roster makeup of Phoenix and what
they're trying to do right now you
should merkitch is a guy who's a great
Pastor you can give him to give him the
ball top of the key people initiate the
offense so they feel like he he's
probably going to be better equipped to
play with stars and Kevin Durant Devin
Booker and Bradley Bill and they just
they just didn't and plus you know the
relationship just wasn't that good
um between Aiden and the sons and I I
know there's a different coaching staff
there as well but
you know still they wanted they just
wanted to have a center that they felt
like with this game will complement
their star players and so you know they
were ready to make a move so they were
just Phoenix was just waiting on
Portland and I'm getting a call from a
star player now but uh
Phoenix was just waiting it's just
waiting on
um Portland to uh to get that third team
to get that 13 figured out and Phoenix
was they were already they were they
were always ready to go all right go
take that phone call Chris Haynes make
sure you go read up on his report that
he's going to have on Bleacher Report
and also check him out on TNT cylons
Chris Haynes dropping knowledge like
Dane drops threes